This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. When designing a commercial structure, the architect must make the hallways wide enough for a wheelchair. The materials must be compatible with its surrounding climate, the beams must be able to support the building and withstand the wind. The building should be dynamic, interesting, comfortable, and ready to be completely abandoned if it burns.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。在设计商业建筑时，建筑师必须确保走廊足够宽，以容纳轮椅。材料必须与周围气候相适应，梁柱必须能够支撑建筑物并抵御风力。建筑物应该是动态的、有趣的、舒适的，并且在发生火灾时能够被完全放弃。
There are a number of considerations for how a building should respond to emergency. Horns versus strobes versus speakers. The pulsating frequency of the light, the intensity of the light, smoke dampening, it goes on and on. There's the sprinklers, the panic bars, you light, the intensity of the light, smoke dampening, it goes on and on. There's the sprinklers, the panic bars, you know, the spring loaded horizontal bar that you push to unlock emergency exit, the smoke detectors, what kinds you use and the distances between them.
关于建筑物应如何应对紧急情况，有许多考量因素。喇叭、频闪灯还是扬声器？光的脉冲频率、光的强度、烟雾阻尼等等，不一而足。还有自动喷水灭火系统、紧急推杆，你知道的，就是那种推开就能解锁紧急出口的弹簧式横杆，还有烟雾探测器，你使用哪种类型以及它们之间的距离。
You know, a lot of people hardly even look up and see these things and they just need to be there when an emergency happens. Now, Adam Wining and Daniel Scoville are architects. We work with them at Arxon in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. Most of the time, when they're working on fire safety, they'll consult experts about where to place what kinds of architectural emergency devices. But there's one safety device that they must design right into the building from the get-go.
你知道，很多人甚至都不会抬头看这些东西，但当紧急情况发生时，它们必须在那里。亚当·威尼克和丹尼尔·斯科维尔是建筑师。我们在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的ArcSign与他们共事。大多数时候，当他们进行消防安全设计时，他们会咨询专家，了解在何处放置何种建筑应急设备。但有一种安全设备，他们必须从一开始就将其直接设计到建筑物中。
It's impossible to ignore. As far as jail locations, that's pretty important right from the start because it changes the whole dynamic of your space. Typically, buildings require two fire stairs, but it all depends on the size and purpose of the structure. In architecture and building codes, you always need a certain number of exits or means of egress so it weighs out of a building.
它是不容忽视的。就监狱位置而言，这从一开始就非常重要，因为它改变了你空间的整体动态。通常，建筑物需要两个消防楼梯，但这完全取决于建筑物的规模和用途。在建筑和建筑规范中，你总是需要一定数量的出口或疏散通道，也就是离开建筑物的方式。
And this fire escape precariously bolted to the side of the building is one of our means of egress out of the space. And this is how 99% of visible is going to escape a burning building. This is how Arxine and 99% of visible are going to escape our burning building. In case of fire, Architects Daniel Skolville and Adam Wynneck and producer Avery Trouffleman would put their steely resolve and athletic prowess to the test. There's this classic rot iron fire escape right outside of our window.
而这个摇摇欲坠地固定在建筑物侧面的消防梯，就是我们离开空间的疏散方式之一。这就是《99%隐形》将如何逃离燃烧的建筑物。这就是ArcSign和《99%隐形》将如何逃离我们燃烧的建筑物。如果发生火灾，建筑师丹尼尔·斯科维尔、亚当·威尼克和制片人艾弗里·特鲁夫曼将考验他们钢铁般的意志和运动能力。我们的窗外就有这个经典的锻铁消防梯。
And I thought it was defunct. It's all rusty and stuff. But then I bothered to read the sign with the evacuation plan for our building. Always read the evacuation plan. Fire escapes are not allowed in new construction. But because we are in a beautiful old brick building, the Firescape is actually one of our means of egress. We just speak of means of egress, thinking of the whole root, the corridor, and the stairs, and you think of an exit as being essentially the door. Professor Sarah Wormiel, Independent Scholar and Researcher at MIT.
我以为它已经废弃了。它锈迹斑斑的。但后来我读了我们大楼的疏散计划标志。一定要阅读疏散计划。新建建筑不允许使用消防梯。但因为我们在一栋美丽的旧砖楼里，消防梯实际上是我们疏散方式的一种。我们谈论疏散方式时，会想到整条路线、走廊和楼梯，而你认为出口本质上就是那扇门。萨拉·沃米尔教授，麻省理工学院的独立学者和研究员。
One of my books is called The Fireproof Building. I can't remember this subtitle. It's The Fireproof Building, Technology and Public Safety in the 19th century American City. The single most dangerous thing for architecture, historically, is fire. And in the 1700s, if a fire did break out, there wasn't a whole lot you could do about it. By that time there were firefighters.
我的一本书叫《防火建筑》。我不记得副标题了。是《防火建筑：19世纪美国城市的科技与公共安全》。从历史上看，对建筑而言，最危险的事情就是火灾。在18世纪，如果真的发生火灾，你对此能做的不多。到那时已经有了消防员。
Whom you summoned by Yelline Loudly. And they would come, and they would bring you the fire escape. It was a cart with a ladder on it. That was actually what the earliest fire escapes were. So fire escape methods started to get incorporated into architecture, starting with the scuttle. It looked like a skylight. It would have some kind of cover. It was like a trap door on the roof, and then there'd be a ladder to get up and out. And so, in a fire, you would climb through the scuttle out onto the roof,
你通过大声呼喊来召唤他们。他们会来，并带给你消防梯。那是一个带有梯子的推车。这实际上就是最早的消防梯。因此，消防逃生方法开始被纳入建筑设计中，从天窗开始。它看起来像个天窗。它会有某种盖子。它就像屋顶上的一个活板门，然后会有一个梯子可以爬上去出去。所以，在火灾中，你会爬过天窗来到屋顶，
hop to your neighbor's scuttle and crawl into their building, which presumably hadn't also caught fire. That was the beginning, this idea that a city could require something for the sake of fire safety. Around 1860, New York begins to require means of egress in tenement buildings. Tenement buildings were tall, flammable, densely packed tinder boxes just full of families. So of course landlords went with the least expensive options. The popular cheap fix was rope. Ropes with baskets that you're supposed to somehow, you know,
跳到邻居的天窗，爬进他们的建筑物，想必那里还没有着火。这就是开始，即城市可以为了消防安全而要求某种设施的想法。1860年左右，纽约开始要求公寓楼必须有疏散通道。公寓楼是高大、易燃、拥挤的火药桶，里面住满了家庭。所以房东当然选择了最便宜的方案。流行的廉价补救措施是绳子。带有篮子的绳子，你得想办法，你知道，
the buildings on fire, you have your kid, you're terrified and you calmly open this little nightstand. Pull out the basket with ropes, you know, set up the apparatus, strap yourself in, and somehow, you know, lower yourself calmly to the ground. You know, it's just preposterous. There are these hilarious old advertisements for fake cabinets and hollow refrigerators and empty washing machines
建筑物着火了，你抱着孩子，你吓坏了，然后你冷静地打开这个小床头柜。拿出装有绳子的篮子，你知道，设置好装置，把自己绑进去，然后以某种方式，你知道，冷静地把自己降到地面。你知道，这简直荒谬。有一些滑稽的旧广告，推销假橱柜、空冰箱和空洗衣机，
so that you can store your ropes and basket apparatus. Because no one would notice that extra washing machine. One engineer actually thought that instead of dispatching ropes from inside, archers could shoot the ropes up to the higher floors. You know, people aren't that athletic necessarily to begin with, but second of all, it's a fire. You know, this isn't the best time to, you know, like figure out how to lower yourself
这样你就可以存放你的绳子和篮子装置。因为没人会注意到那台多余的洗衣机。一位工程师甚至认为，与其从内部部署绳子，不如让弓箭手把绳子射到高层。你知道，人们本身不一定那么有运动天赋，但其次，这是火灾。你知道，这不是你弄清楚如何把自己降下去的最佳时机，
on a rope. Another patent proposed individual parachute hats with accompanying rubber shoes to break the fall. There are also these big slide fire escapes that were largely marketed to schools as both emergency devices and playground equipment. There actually used to be a giant spiral slide to escape the Claremont Hotel right here in Oakland, which would have made that place a whole lot better. There were lots of ideas, but by the 1870s, firescapes began becoming something iron, something fixed to the building.
用一根绳子。另一项专利提议使用带有配套橡胶鞋的个人降落伞帽来缓冲坠落。还有一些大型滑梯式消防梯，主要作为紧急设备和游乐场设备向学校推销。在奥克兰的克莱蒙特酒店，曾经确实有一个巨大的螺旋滑梯用于逃生，那会让那个地方好得多。有很多想法，但到了1870年代，消防梯开始变成铁制的，固定在建筑物上的东西。
Although by that point, they still weren't anything great. They were like an iron platform outside of a window with straight ladders attached, or it might just be a straight ladder clamp to the wall. In some cities, the external ladders angled and widened to become more like stairs. This was an improvement, of course, but ultimately, fire escapes just didn't suffice. And it took a terrible tragedy to show this. So the ash building in New York
尽管到那时，它们仍然不是什么好东西。它们就像窗外的一个铁平台，上面连着直梯，或者可能只是夹在墙上的直梯。在一些城市，外部梯子倾斜并加宽，变得更像楼梯。这当然是一种改进，但最终，消防梯还是不够用。一场可怕的悲剧证明了这一点。所以纽约的阿什大楼，
was built as a loft building, and its owners represented it as being, you know, maybe for warehousing, not necessarily for manufacturing. Based on its dimensions, the ash building was required to have three means of egress, but the developer insisted that the property would just be used as warehousing. So rather than three stairs, he was allowed to put in two stairs and a thin fire escape. Then the owner rents the top three floors of the ash building to the Triangle Shirt Waste Company. In March of 1911, there's a fire in the buildings, it's not knowing exactly how it
被建成了一栋阁楼式建筑，业主将其描述为，你知道，可能是用于仓储，不一定是用于制造。根据其尺寸，阿什大楼被要求有三个疏散通道，但开发商坚持认为该物业只会用作仓储。所以他被允许安装两个楼梯和一个薄薄的消防梯，而不是三个楼梯。然后业主把阿什大楼的顶层三层租给了三角衬衫腰公司。1911年3月，大楼发生火灾，不知道具体是怎么
begins and it spreads quickly. The 10th floor has an exit to the roof. So many of the 10th floor workers are able to survive by taking the stairs up, and the workers on the 8th floor are by and large, able to get out. But workers on the 9th floor were trapped. The doors of the stairs opened inward
开始的，火势蔓延很快。10楼有一个通往屋顶的出口。所以许多10楼的工人能够通过走楼梯上去而幸存下来，8楼的工人也大体上能够逃脱。但9楼的工人被困住了。楼梯的门是向内开的，
and became blocked with bodies. And the stairs were backed up with workers exiting from the floors below. So workers on the ninth floor couldn't even get down. Only a few workers on this floor knew about the 10th floor exit. And so they didn't even try to go upstairs. There was a charge that one of the doors was locked. And this wasn't proved to the trial, but I believe even if it had been, with all the people
被尸体堵住了。楼梯里挤满了从下面楼层撤离的工人。所以9楼的工人甚至无法下楼。这一层只有少数工人知道10楼的出口。所以他们甚至没有尝试上楼。有人指控其中一扇门被锁上了。这在审判中没有得到证实，但我相信即使证实了，考虑到所有从
exiting from the eighth floor and the staircases were very narrow and winding, there just wasn't the capacity. Some workers tried to use the outside fire escape, and it collapsed under the weight. It was from the windows of the ninth floor that many workers desperate to escape the flames and smoke fell or jumped to their deaths. 146 people lost their lives right in the middle of Grinch Village. There were a lot of witnesses. It was horrible.
8楼撤离的人，而且楼梯非常狭窄蜿蜒，根本没有足够的容量。一些工人试图使用外部消防梯，结果在重压下坍塌了。正是从9楼的窗户，许多绝望地逃离火焰和烟雾的工人坠落或跳楼身亡。146人在格林威治村中心丧生。有很多目击者。太可怕了。
But the building was fine. The ash building was a fireproof building. And of course, it's still standing. And it's now part of New York University. The ash building, now called the Brown Building, was well-made, which is why at the time no one really thought it needed egress. Exits in egress were a problem people thought for the tenements and the poor quality buildings.
但建筑物本身没问题。阿什大楼是一栋防火建筑。当然，它现在仍然屹立不倒。它现在是纽约大学的一部分。阿什大楼，现在叫布朗大楼，建造得很好，这就是为什么当时没人认为它需要疏散通道。人们认为出口和疏散通道是公寓和劣质建筑的问题。
The logic was, if a building was first class, it was in and of itself safe for the occupants. And then the people could just be safely locked inside of these non-combustible buildings. The triangle fire proved that architecture couldn't protect us. We had to protect ourselves from architecture. This is when an organization called the National Fire Protection Association does a lot of studies in thinking about egress. And good egress meant getting rid of fire escapes for so many reasons. They weren't commonly used, so they were often out of order in states of disrepair. In northern
逻辑是，如果一栋建筑是一流的，它本身对居住者来说就是安全的。然后人们就可以安全地锁在这些不可燃的建筑物里。三角火灾证明了建筑无法保护我们。我们必须保护自己免受建筑的伤害。这时，一个名为美国国家消防协会的组织开始对疏散进行大量研究和思考。良好的疏散意味着出于多种原因摆脱消防梯。它们不常使用，因此经常处于失修状态。在北部
climates, they were covered with snow, were eroded by rain, and not everyone could access them, like people with disabilities, and the very young, and the elderly, and women who were hamstrung by the fashion of the time. Women in these long skirts might not have the presence of wine to take off their skirt so they could actually get out. Also fire escapes are scary. You see some narrow, rickety staircases on really tall buildings that make you feel like you should strap on rubber shoes and a parachute hat. And if people weren't used to using fire escapes, they often didn't know where they were. People try to leave the way they came in, you know, that's what they think of.
气候中，它们被雪覆盖，被雨水侵蚀，而且并非每个人都能使用它们，比如残疾人、非常年幼的人、老年人，以及被当时时尚束缚的女性。穿着长裙的女性可能没有那种冷静去脱掉裙子，以便她们能真正逃出去。此外，消防梯很可怕。你看到一些高大建筑物上狭窄、摇摇欲坠的楼梯，让你觉得你应该穿上橡胶鞋，戴上降落伞帽。如果人们不习惯使用消防梯，他们通常不知道它们在哪里。人们试图从他们进来的地方离开，你知道，他们就是这么想的。
And that's where modern fire escapes come in. They're not bolted to the side of the building. They are the logical place where you would go in an emergency. They are the stairs. Well they look like normal stairs, but really they're pieces of emergency equipment enclosed in fireproof walls and sealed with a self-closing door and covered with sprinklers and alarms. And because they work perfectly well as stairways, they're often the stairway in a building. So the building won't have the grand stairway any longer. It'll have lots of elevators and the fire stairs.
这就是现代消防梯的用武之地。它们不是用螺栓固定在建筑物侧面的。它们是你在紧急情况下会去的合乎逻辑的地方。它们就是楼梯。它们看起来像普通的楼梯，但实际上它们是封闭在防火墙内、用自动关闭门密封并覆盖有喷水灭火系统和警报器的应急设备。而且因为它们作为楼梯工作得非常好，它们通常就是建筑物里的楼梯。所以建筑物不再有宏伟的楼梯。它会有很多电梯和消防楼梯。
Good by opulent lobbies with sweeping grand stairways. If you like to take the stairs, you've probably already bemoaned the fact that they are always shoved off into a tower and are very cold and industrial, no matter what the building looks like from the outside. If we want, we can make them look good, but most clients elect to spend their money on things that people are going to see more. Office made in architect Adam Wineck again.
再见，豪华的大厅和宽阔的宏伟楼梯。如果你喜欢走楼梯，你可能已经抱怨过它们总是被挤进一个塔楼里，而且非常寒冷和工业化，无论建筑物从外面看起来是什么样。如果我们愿意，我们可以让它们看起来不错，但大多数客户选择把钱花在人们会看到更多的地方。建筑师亚当·威尼克再次说道。
The stairways need to be what's called rated, meaning that they need to be enclosed in a type of construction that won't melt or allow the fire to penetrate as quickly as a non-rated wall. These rated towers can be like buildings within buildings. The prime example of a souped-up fire stairway is in Freedom Tower. The Freedom Tower, which has this emergency core, which is on its own separate electrical and plumbing system, and has its own elevator, its own stairs. That's Elijah Huge. He's a professor at Wesleyan University. And I'm also a practicing architect, and I run a small firm called Periphery Projects, and part of that Periphery involves doing research on architecture and emergency.
楼梯需要是所谓的“额定”的，这意味着它们需要封闭在一种不会熔化或让火势像非额定墙那样快速穿透的结构中。这些额定塔楼就像建筑中的建筑。超级消防楼梯的典型例子是自由塔。自由塔，它有这个应急核心，它有自己独立的电气和管道系统，并且有自己的电梯，自己的楼梯。那是伊莱贾·休。他是卫斯理大学的教授。我也是一名执业建筑师，我经营一家名为Periphery Projects的小公司，而Periphery的一部分工作涉及对建筑和紧急情况的研究。
He's particularly fascinated by these core structures around the fire's dairs. And these emergency cores are modeled with software and simulations dedicated solely to egress. This program Exodus 4.0 I think there's now Exodus 5.0 can simulate how quickly a floor of a building can be cleared based on the maximum number of bodies that would be allowed in this space, how quickly could those bodies exit this space. So the architect or actually more likely the consultant will plug in the measurements of a building, all the information about its emergency equipment, the maximum number of occupants, and basically click play
他特别着迷于消防楼梯周围的这些核心结构。这些应急核心是用专门用于疏散的软件和模拟程序建模的。这个程序Exodus 4.0，我想现在有Exodus 5.0，可以模拟基于该空间允许的最大人数，一层楼能以多快的速度被清空，这些人能以多快的速度离开这个空间。所以建筑师，或者更可能是顾问，会输入建筑物的测量数据、所有关于其应急设备的信息、最大居住人数，然后基本上点击播放，
and watch the digital people escape the pixel flames. A lot of agent-based modeling programs with humans don't work terribly well because humans don't necessarily behave predictably, but in emergencies they do. Given adequate signage, people will behave in predictable ways in the event of an emergency. So this makes sense. We've already established that in an emergency, people don't want to go places they haven't gone to before, or use devices they've never seen, or figure out if they can catch a rope,
看着数字人在像素火焰中逃生。很多基于人类的代理建模程序效果并不好，因为人类的行为不一定可预测，但在紧急情况下，他们确实如此。如果有足够的标识，人们在紧急情况下会以可预测的方式行事。所以这很有道理。我们已经确定，在紧急情况下，人们不想去他们以前没去过的地方，或者使用他们从未见过的设备，或者弄清楚他们是否能接住一根绳子，
shot at them with a bow and arrow. The way Egress works now is in keeping with the way that we use buildings normally. Even though rated towers take up a lot of space and money and make for an unpleasant stepping experience, it's hard to argue with this solution. It's paid off, let's say. Sarah Wormiel again. For 2012, in non-residential structures, there were 65 deaths in the whole year. You know, probably more people were struck by lightning.
用弓箭射向他们。现在的疏散方式与我们正常使用建筑物的方式保持一致。尽管额定塔楼占用了大量空间和资金，并且导致了不愉快的步行体验，但很难反驳这个解决方案。可以说，它得到了回报。萨拉·沃米尔再次说道。2012年，在非住宅建筑中，全年有65人死亡。你知道，可能被闪电击中的人更多。
Actually, 28 people were struck by lightning in 2012, but still, even though each one is a tragedy, 65 deaths doesn't strike me as all that many. This number is already down from 2003, where there were 220 deaths in non-residential buildings, so these are the buildings with heavy regulations and core structures. Modern emergency equipment and egress procedures are really helping to minimize the effects of fire accidents. But from an aesthetic standpoint, it's almost a pity, because fire escapes are beautiful. And although I'm not really thrilled at the prospect of clamoring down the fire escape outside my window, I do like to look at it. And for Sarah Wormill, fire escapes, even the ones that are no longer in use, are this physical
实际上，2012年有28人被闪电击中，但即便如此，虽然每一个都是悲剧，但65人死亡在我看来并不算多。这个数字已经比2003年有所下降，当时非住宅建筑有220人死亡，所以这些是受到严格监管和核心结构保护的建筑物。现代应急设备和疏散程序确实有助于最大限度地减少火灾事故的影响。但从美学角度来看，这几乎是一种遗憾，因为消防梯很美。虽然我并不太热衷于爬下窗外的消防梯，但我确实喜欢看它。对于萨拉·沃米尔来说，消防梯，即使是那些不再使用的，也是这种物理上的
reminder that we evolve past being a culture that says, here's a rope, good luck buddy. I just like seeing them and hope that they'll be preserved because it just makes me realize how we kind of have to work together as a society. You have to rely on other people to put in the stairs to follow the rules for the rules to be there, and that's what makes us safe. I am somewhere in the city, I am climbing up a fire escape. I am somewhere in the city, I am climbing up a fire escape. I have got to save my baby from a mess this world has made."
提醒，提醒我们已经进化，不再是一个说“给你一根绳子，祝你好运”的文化。我只是喜欢看到它们，并希望它们能被保存下来，因为这让我意识到我们作为一个社会是如何需要共同努力的。你必须依靠其他人来安装楼梯，遵守规则，让规则存在，这就是让我们安全的原因。我身处城市某处，我正在爬消防梯。我身处城市某处，我正在爬消防梯。我必须从这个世界制造的混乱中拯救我的孩子。
99% Invisible was produced this week by Avery Trouffleman, with Sam Greenspan, Katie Mingle, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and produced of the offices of ArcSign in beautiful, downtown Oakland, California. If you like the stories on this program, you can get more and more and more stories and correspond with all the people who make this show on Facebook, Twitter and Tumblr. But there are more fire escapes and you can shake a stick at 99pi.org. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本周的《99%隐形》由艾弗里·特鲁夫曼制作，山姆·格林斯潘、凯蒂·明格和我罗曼·马斯参与。我们是旧金山91.7本地公共广播电台KALW的一个项目，并在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的ArcSign办公室制作。如果你喜欢这个节目中的故事，你可以在Facebook、Twitter和Tumblr上获得更多故事，并与制作这个节目的所有人交流。但在99pi.org上，还有更多的消防梯供你探索。来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。